Speaker 1: All right. This has been a long time
coming and I'm super excited and nervous about
this because I don't know how it's going to go.
I've teased for a while that we've been working
on a children's book on critical thinking. As
so many of you know, I've identified one of the
many problems we have in education in the United
States is we're not teaching critical thinking
to kids nearly early enough. I've written with
our team a book for kids on critical thinking. I
have the first proof right in front of me and I'm
holding it up. This one labeled Not for Resale.
This book is now available on Amazon.
We did an email blast this morning and
the copies are flying off the shelves.
It is. Unbelievable what's going on?
I don't pretend for a second that this 40 page
book, including illustrations and dedication
and everything that this 40 page book is going
to solve the critical thinking crisis we have.
But this is a book that six, seven, eight year
olds can read with their parents. Nine, ten,
11, 12 year olds can read by themselves.
It is about starting to think critically
when someone says something. How do we know that
it's true? How do we know that we know anything?
I can't tell you. I've heard from people saying,
David, I'm buying 25 copies. I'm going to bring
them to my local libraries and give them give them
away. I'm buying these as gifts for I don't have
kids, but I'm buying them for my my nephews and
so on and so forth. It's available in Kindle and
in paperback. The Kindle is preorder. It's going
to launch Tuesday. Preorder it now. Please help
us with the preorders. Only a couple hundred
preorders can put us at number one for the
category. This is you know, we're used to hundreds
of thousands and millions being the numbers we
talk about on YouTube and podcast, etc.. A few
hundred orders of this book today will put us
at the top of the category. And then all bets
are off. I want to also mention that this copy
I have here is the first proof. We're going to
call it like proof zero. I am going to give this
proof away to someone who buys the book. I'll tell
you how to take advantage of that in the future.
Everybody who buys it will be eligible. So I'll
be doing that. I'll give this copy away. I got
two proofs. One I'm going to save for my daughter,
who, by the way, loves the book already. She can't
read. She just loved the pictures. Probably is
going to rip the book up very, very soon. So I
may need to get a couple more proofs. You go to
David Packman dot com slash book. That's it. David
Packman dot com slash book. Make sure to leave a
review Kindle paperback. I'm going to update you
on how this goes. But it is a super exciting new
thing that we're doing and it is only available
at David Packman dot com slash book. We'll take
a quick break and be back right after this.